hi in this video we would look at to
heat hypothesis which is related to
cancer progression this hypothesis was
given by Alfred Kunsan who was an
American physician and a geneticist so
this hypothesis is stated as most genes
required to mutations to cause a
phenotypic change right we would
understand what that means
before that we try to understand what
was his observation so as a physician he
observed few things so he performs
statistical analysis in case of retinal
blastoma which is a tumor generally
present in the very young child and it
is in it could be inherited or it could
be sporadic in nature as well so this is
how a normal eye look like in case of
retinoblastoma the retina looks like
this it's a cancer of AI he found that
retinoblastoma which could be both
familiar and it's parodic but in case of
the familial retina blastoma people who
had history of retinal blastoma in their
family the inherited retinal blastoma
occurs had been way younger age than the
sporadic cases so that individuals are
getting affected by this tumor at a very
early age by in case of sporadic the
onset is late in addition to that the
childrens which have which have like
inherited format of reciprocal customer
a familial form of retinoblastoma in
that case the phenotype is severe both
the eyes are affected
based on these two hypotheses he thought
that there might be some predisposition
in case of the familial region of the
stoma which is augmented by other
reasons whereas in case of sporadic
situation there is no predisposition
that's why the augmentation is bit more
difficult and that's why it is mostly
occurring on the
at all stages not in the very young
stages so now we know that any of the
gene has two versions right in two
different chromosomes so the gene PRB
also has two versions now both these
cases the one of the possibility is like
one of these versions is mutated right
so the protein that is produced from the
version would be not produced but there
is another version of that gene which is
functional so some amount of protein
production would be there now let's say
there is a problem in both the versions
as a result either the production won't
be there or a mutated form worktop
protein would be produced right and as
there could be a different consequences
in terms of phenotypes in case of
familial latino blastoma where the
original custom onset is very early age
there what happens is there are like
already one genetic mutation in the PRB
chain the probability that the second
copy gets mutated is very high and
that's why mostly these original
blastoma are seen in early ages where
whereas in sporadic retinoblastoma both
the copies are initially fine now in
order to get to simultaneous hit in two
different locus the probability is
pretty low so it takes a lot of time so
generally the sporadic cases of
retinoblastoma occurs normally at like
adult ages not generally in the young
ages okay so we learned about that bit
about the genetics behind the two-hit
hypothesis but what is the cell biology
behind two hypotheses what actually it's
performed by rich no grass to massage
that it leads to a plant's cancer so we
know that the initial phase of the cell
cycle
is the interface and in the interphase
the longest phase is the g1 in g1 phase
the cell receives signal
from the environment such as from growth
factors and decide whether it has to
divide or not if the growth factor is
present and the environment is
permissible for division then what
happens is the cells would first
transcribe cycling D now the cyclin D
would phosphorylate a tumor suppressor
gene which is the PRB in our case once
PR b is suppressed and phosphorylated
then e to F can lead to transcription of
S phase cycling which would allow for
progression from 1t1 to s now imagine we
have this normal PR b gene a normal PR b
gene product which is inhibiting e to F
so it would inhibit growth it works like
a tumor suppressor right and the way
inhibit growth is not allowing the cell
cycle to progress from g1 to s unless
and until there is a growth factor in
the environment and in presence of
growth factor this inhibition is
withdrawn but think about a situation
where this PRP is mutated in that
situation there is no one to prevent e
to F form binding so it doesn't require
any growth factor signaling for PR b
mediated suppression to go away it looks
like the e to F is constitutively active
so the cells no matter how they receive
the signal from the outside they always
decide to transit from the g1 to s and
as a result uncontrolled growth take
place which is very much similar to a
phosphorylated format of PRP where PR we
cannot inhibit in E to F and E to F is
free to transcribe psych liens which are
required for S phase and as a results
you want to S transition happen and as a
consequence of all of these the tumor
forms in the retina and that's the story
behind Richelieu blastoma and two-hit
hypothesis I hope this video was
informative if you like this video give
it a quick thumbs up don't forget to
Like share and subscribe thank you
you